all right guys let's get started
camera will help me hear me okay cool
all right
um hi everyone I'm Li Jing very happy to
be here today and thanks for coming to
the last session of the day today I'm
going to talk about improving pandas and
pi spark Interop with a passion arrow so
a little bit about me I'm a staff
engineer working at 2 Sigma investments
to see my investments is a company based
based in New York we're a technology
company that applies data science in a
field of Finance and we love Python
I recently become a patchy Erica meter
which I will talk about a little bit
about a patch area later
I also working in the field of building
and data analysis tools which I'm very
passionate about I also worked on other
open source projects such as Flint which
is a time serious library on spark and
cook affair schedule missus so this talk
will be more of a case study and
walkthrough of how do we improve a
interrupts problem between Java and
Python we found in PI spark and how you
use a passion arrow to significantly
improve the situation
this talk will will briefly be a high
spark overview how many of you guys have
heard of PI spark and how many guys use
PI spark for research for engineering
awesome so I can probably be a little
bit quicker about that then I'm going to
focus on a specific area of Pi spar
which I think need improvements which is
Python UTS then I'm going to talk about
a patch arrow what is it why it's
interesting what oops why you should
care about it and I will talk about
improvements to to pass back UDF that we
can make with a patch arrow and finish
with future roadmaps sorry these things
- hopefully it's all good all right
let's talk about high spot so Apache
spark is a tool for I think it's a tool
for distributed data analysis
it's a Patrick project which means open
it's gray and it's mostly a jpn based
technology which means the core spark is
is running on jvn but it comes with a
Python interface for pi spark spark
comes with different functionalities
organized in different modules there is
a relational module that deals with
joint data grouping data some
aggregation statistics and there is
Sparkman ml lab which is a spark module
for stats and machine honey and spark
also do with streaming data and why
should you care about spell why don't
you just use pandas and everything else
along with it well I think there's two
reasons I found spark very appealing to
me and the problem we're facing two
sigma the first is spark can deal with a
bigger data than than pandas pandas is
designed for something I would say Oh
along the range of 10 gigabytes memory
data set in memory it works really great
with the sight of medium sized data but
when you want to go out to let's say a
terabyte of data then it comes struggle
it's no it's no building support for
that and also most of the algorithms in
panas and numpy the single-threaded
they're designed for running really fast
on single core harvests part is more of
a parallelism solution where it scales
you'll scare your own computation but
it's not how many clothes you have so
whenever you're family we wanted more
parallelism and if your data is too big
too filling the the pendant pendant the
pendant era dime then it might be
interesting to look at something like
spark apologize again okay okay I
probably just need to be more gentle
about that
[Music]
so with this or this pie spot hi spark
is the Python interface for spark it
mostly has two major excuse me can you
actually help me
Oh with the connection okay so I would
say as I was saying spark mostly has two
major use cases one is pice box provides
its API front-end for the beauty and
spark functions the example here I give
is you just want to compute +1 on comm
this this line of code here is written
in Python but actually the computation
itself has nothing to do with Python the
code x-ray is translated into Java code
and running in a JVM the second case
here of price bug is it provides
interface to run native Python code
through this function called
user-defined functions similarly I'm
giving the same computation here but by
using a UDF here I'm doing +1 through a
pattern and the function and this code
is actually going to be a run Python the
way it works is a spark will send the
data from the Java JVM to a Python
process invoke this vendor function and
send results back and today this talk is
going to be mostly focusing on the
second use case which is UDF's now I'm
going to talk about the current state
and limitations of PI spar UDF's again
UDF's
is PI Spock's interface to interact with
other Python libraries we're going to
focus on two types of UDF's
here bones rody UDF and group qdf really
the F is just very simple concept
it's a UDF that operates on row by row
basis it's similar to a map row
operation examples here people usually
won't use road UDF's for something like
stream processing maybe talking as a
string or you want to do some time stamp
processing run at times them to some
business days etc really DF is really
simple to use but it's pretty limited
because it has no great performance
usually we found row UDF it's about 1 to
2 orders of magnitudes
lower their alternatives which can be
either a sparkling functions or a
optimized Python vectorized operation
the second type of UDF is group view
death which is UDF that operates on
multiple rows this is similar to a group
5 operator followed by a map operator
examples here you can become you want to
compute multi with a main or something
that can be done after a group back so
this type of UDF is now supported out of
the box you can do it with Spock but
it's really hard to do as we were seeing
a second also suffers from the similar
performance issue as a roadie BF here
I'm going to give a quick example of
just what I just want to calculate
values following this formula I want to
subtract the me and divided by the
standard deviation of the values maybe
by each month and here's the code you
have to write to do it in PI spot oops
even the screen doesn't like it yeah the
code is probably too bad even the screen
kind of hates it anyway you don't need
to read a code but ideas to show you how
complicated it is to perform this simple
operation and if we take a look at
closer 80% of the code is actually the
boilerplate you just need these four
lines actually to compute to express
this computation and the code is slope
just because we had so many overhead in
the increasing are creating these
intermediate steps so we found to
summarize we found there's two issues
with the UDF in PI's part first because
of the it has this JVM and Python issue
and has to move data between them to
actually invoke the UDF the data
movement is actually pretty expensive
because of the inefficiency also the
scalar computation model is just not
great operating row-by-row is just not
gonna work for if you have a lot of data
so how can we have how can we use
something that can solve this problem
now a patch Harrow comes to rescue so
what is a passion arrow
apache arrow is a
is in memory columnar format its beauty
it's built on top of a successor pocket
and it's open so standard from the start
which means it has developers from a lot
of major open source projects getting
involved in the design phase to make
sure the format agree on the format and
they think they can work for them the
benefit of introducing something like
arrow in in the space of data analysis
is it can should effort and create an
ecosystem we discrete about Python I
think is basically every Python
libraries knows how to deal with number
arrays and painless data frames and the
Pesce arrow is trying to solve this
problem not just within Python but
across different languages so the idea
be you have two systems maybe one in
Java
maybe we in Python maybe something else
in Judea or R and you want kind of use
them in a integrated environment and if
they can all talk with each other using
Apache arrow then the overhead is
significantly reduced here's just
another simple illustration of idea
without arrow for each pair of system if
they want to talk to each other you have
to they have to do first the developer
have to write a specific code to convert
the different format and also that code
is probably not efficient enough because
it involves a lot of copy copy and paste
the idea with arrow is if everyone knows
how to convert the data structure to
arrow or better if they can use arrow
internally as the data structure then
they can just talk to each other and
much easier to give another taste just
to give a taste of what the arrow data
structure looks like here I'm showing a
person's record so there are two records
here and each record has three columns
as you can see they can be a straight
simple single columns like string
integers or they can be something more
complicated like an acid of phone
numbers things like that and on the
right side you can see how arrow
represents this in memory it's actually
very flat for each of the columns the
values is actually stored in a flat
array and in order to present either the
variable there
or the NASA data structure arrow adds on
a few offset arrays on top of it so it's
really as you can see it's really easy
to say if you want to flatten the phone
numbers into a single array and use them
in aggregations or counting on that it's
really easy because the values is just
already flattened here is just another
kind of presentation of the alloy data
structure within a kind of uniform
memory layout point of view do you have
another cable that's it it's another
screening poaches again and this is the
arrow format from a memory point of view
the point of here is to show actually
this vectors are all just contiguous
memory contiguous bytes blocks in memory
actually an arrow is organized into this
idea of Drecker patches so a record
batches can be you know a few color
that's in five columns with like 10,000
records and for each tracker patches
it is just contiguous memory it all
always comes with the data header so you
can jump into the specific columns you
want very very fast and also these
different different value vectors can be
accessed very efficiently using offsets
arrow is really designed for high
performance which means it's designed
for maximize the CPU throughput by using
things like pipelining or simply
orchestral cavity also arrow is grateful
sky together IO which which means you
can write a single string of IO into
multiple buffers very efficiently using
just the OS operation finally I want to
show some results of the current
applications of the arrow you can read
more in detail on the arrow broth but
idea is it's pretty performance in all
cases so now let's talk about improving
anti-spark UDF's using arrow how do we
use the square technology to help the
situation so we did two things here
first thing is we we back to us the row
row UDF's
again to kind of remind ourselves the
way it currently works as you have well
executed process which is a GVM process
and you have a paddle walker process and
upon executing this UDF spark will
ascend rose from the executor to the
python worker in this pickle format and
upon receiving these rows the Python
Walter will invoke this UDF which is a
row based so it's gonna do this row by
row
and send results back after stone this
is a super simple but also again as we
mentioned earlier it's not very
efficient to further illustrate this we
took a profiling of executing this
simple UDF lambda X + 1
I love ump ump ice bar using their
existing UDF's and there's a few things
I want to talk about here first is the
overall throughput of computing the
simple operations it's kind of bad it's
only a megabytes per second so it's as
bad by any standard - for simple
computation the second thing on high is
actually we found over 90% of the
running time is spent on the
civilization and the sterilization code
it's a lot of overhead so what we end up
doing is we build a 2
converters filled out spark executor to
turn spark roasts to and from Aruba I'll
record batches and across the wire
instead of standing as pickled rows we
sell this error immutable arrow fetches
and upon receiving dispatchers instead
of applying the UDA power row by row
basis now the pattern Walker can apply a
vectorized to UDF on each batch so it's
a scenario spec afterwards so this is
the same benchmark results we did before
and after the change and before I will
see it takes about four seconds and
after it only takes less than 100
milliseconds so it's a great speed up
first of all and second of all if we
look a little bit closer we can see all
the overhead of sterilization and
destabilization are removed from the
from the bottom version you cannot find
any of these overhead here and last but
not least even the i/o pad is more
efficient because because I will utilize
scatter gather IO you end up being
having much less system cost and two IO
cos and end up having much faster IO so
the second improvement we made is
improving a group UDF's the way we did
it we introduced this group Judea on
this function called group croup I apply
which is a very simple notion I'm sure
you all know about it
it's a basic idea is to break a problem
into smaller pieces I'll put it on each
pieces independently and put the pieces
back together it's a common function of
supporting a lot of languages pandas are
spark sequel they all support that so
what we did here is we utilize the
existing group I and combine operators
in spark and we just changed apply step
to support you DFS with which which now
the EDF takes a function from a panda's
data frame to another pandas dataframe
just to go by the slide that you have
now is a transformation on a panda's
data frame
here's just a Ellis tration of what's
happening under the hood spark organized
data in different blogs on different
machines and the group I will trigger a
shuffle phase which sent the data to its
correct guru and for each group we we
can then we apply the UDF on each group
and get a results back
let's go back to our previous example we
want to run this simple computation and
data breaking by month and here's the
code before an active before this
terrible a lot of overhead and
afterwards it's reasonably well I
wouldn't say it's it's perfect but it's
reasonably well easy to understand read
and write and the core the major of the
computation is just the middle on here
which is just a painless operation so
this API is actually this slide is made
a little bit earlier so it's the API has
changed since then you can refer to
either the PI spark dogs or this blog
link I have over here for the the most
up-to-date API so finally let's look at
some quick performance comparisons we
run a few different computations and
comparing them like comparing the row
version versus the vectorized version
and we okay this is it's clearly the
vector version is much much better we
achieve anywhere from 3x speed up to a
hundred X speed up depending on the
computation and we are quite happy about
results so if you think that's
interesting if you have faced the same
problem you use spark you wanna make PI
spark integrated with pandas a little
bit better you can try this out this
feature will be available upcoming
apache spark release and you can also
try this today actually with the data
breaks community version which is a
company that provides hosted spark
support and you can try this out for
free and I wrote this blog earlier to
explain the work in more detail so if
you interested take a look so finally
just some future roadmaps
here's the Jairam this is a master G
recovers other issues with high spot
pending capability we have more things
we want to do in the area so you can
watch a voted comment if you want and on
our site we're working really hard
towards every 1.0 release which will
make things much more stabilized and
api's and the binary representation also
just to look forward to more arrow
integration I think there's a lot of
talks in PI data there's a dremmel talk
tomorrow about integrating areas Jamiel
there's probably some other work going
on so this madness if you want get
involved through feel free to to post
anything here just the people I work
with to make this happen very very how
about happy about that with that I will
finish my talk and a happy to take
questions go ahead please yeah
the way PI spark works is Python always
spin up spark always brings up this
Python process for running UDF's
and unless it's UDF's you actually
doesn't need just start up the patent
process so it's purely for the purpose
of evaluating UF's go ahead I cannot
answer to the specific format of feather
because I'm not very familiar but I
think they kind of converge at some
point I think if feather is actually
part of arrow right now or yeah I think
it's yeah it's yeah they probably just
merged them as point fellows for all
right yeah yeah I think I think it gets
this is a blog of West McKenna I think
wrote a blog on that sometime earlier -
about about putting feather into arrow
and some performance speed up after
doing that so you can check it out go
ahead please there's some typecasting
down for this specific use case the tab
casting is done on the PI arrow side so
pyro has functions you can cast a long
to double up casting or down casting so
it's purely down there is that is that a
question
go ahead please yeah yeah the in type I
think a very important use case of UDF's
is you can use any pattern libraries
with that because you basically you have
this Python process running and whatever
this process the Python process had
access to you have it in your UDF's good
sorry of saying how does right arrow as
a so-so
erase actually zero copy to penis so if
you do arrow typos two panels at zero
copy so it's basically like you can use
any any pattern libraries with arrow
format just because arrow can get into
panels so easily
alright thanks oh thanks for coming
again
[Applause]